[Music]
I honestly can't remember why we kept
most of this stuff to begin with we used
to love flying that with mother and
father those days are long behind me
[Music]
I live in break
[Music]
MARY POPPINS who came back you seemed
hardly to have aged at all really one
never discusses a woman's age Michael
would have hoped I taught you better
[Music]
what brings you here after all this time
same thing that brought me the first
time I've come to look after the bank's
children oh yes you too
what about to lose our home if he's
fallen to pieces since your mother
[Music]
famous mother nothing's gone forever
only out of place it's good thing you
come along when you did Mary Poppins
[Music]
do what
[Music]
so you've been off filling the
children's heads with stuff and nonsense
you forgot what it's like to be a child
[Music]
[Music]
everything is possible for the
impossible
[Music]
Oh freak you
[Music]
you need to be more careful when the
wind rises George you mean lost your
kite pad you too
nearly lost your Georgie you might have
got away completely had I not been
holding onto the other end of that
string my goodness Annabelle have you
done to your clothes you could grow a
garden in that much soil and John yes
just as filthy how do you know our names
because she's Mary Poppins it comes may
I show you look lovely as always do you
really think so nice to see you jack
good to see you too Mary Poppins buxom
mares Cubs and O's welcome to our show
of shows it is my great honor to
introduce this evening's renowned guest
the one the only
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
D flat major looks as though they broken
your carriage wheel it's useless now
useless is a chocolate teapot the bone
is speaking and who do we think is gonna
fix that ah there's the riddle then what
broke it fixes it that's what I say what
do you think Mary Poppins well I suppose
we have no choice but how are we going
to do that I know good that fixing
carriages but we can't fix the carriage
wheel it isn't possible everything is
possible even the impossible gather
round everyone spit-spot
Georgie you don't forget Gilly are we
ready
ready
[Music]
[Music]
whatever you talking about where did you
get that kite I found in the box she
kept it for blowing away
[Music]
MARY POPPINS eclipse your mouthpiece
Michael we are still not a codfish gene
banks still rather inclined to giggle I
see good heavens it really is you you
seem hardly to have aged at all really
how incredibly rude one never discusses
a woman's age Michael would have hoped
I've taught you better
I'm sorry I didn't think back I thought
we'd never see you again it's wonderful
to see you
yes it is isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
very puppets it is wonderful to see you
yesterday isn't it does my great honor
to introduce seedlings renowned guests
the one
MARY POPPINS returns really is the next
chapter the first film is a classic one
of Disney's most prized possessions that
character impacted people in such a big
way and this film is not a remake of
Mary Poppins which i think is an
impossible thing but a sequel holding
Jack our film is set 25 years after the
first film the banks children are now
grown up and Michael Banks has three
children of his own and times are hard
in London and Michael does in danger of
losing his home in comes Mary Poppins to
take care of the banks family again well
brings you here after all this time same
thing that brought me the first time
I've come to look after the banks
children yes oh yes you too Emily Blunt
is the perfect Mary Poppins there would
be no film without her it is a part
she's born to play she's got a great
sense of comic timing no pish posh she's
just practically perfect in every way
it's wonderful to see you yes it is
isn't it
well I mean the scale is it is huge I've
never done a film on this scale before
the entire creative team have really
taken painstaking measures to evoke that
sense of childlike joy and Wonder
that's the thing about this movie
there's so much color and exuberance
don't we all need to be reminded of
magic in life we all need that we all
need a Mary Poppins in our life this
experience will always hold a special
place in my life
because this is a film with great hope
and spectacle and it's moving so I think
it's a very important film to be making
right now
everyone are you sure this is quite safe
lives in the slide she's ready
[Music]
you